foreign
[Music]
few historical films are as wildly
popular today as gladiator from the year
2000 which tells the turbulent life of
Roman General Maximus in about two and a
half hours with many epic scenes that
make it a well-rounded story with a
definite conclusion it was therefore a
big surprise when after more than two
decades those in charge actually
announced the production of a sequel in
today's original we take a look at the
plot the production and the cast of the
sequel and provide you with a summary of
all the relevant information in doing so
spoilers to part 1 are inevitable so if
you haven't seen the classic yet you
should definitely do so otherwise enjoy
our brief preview of Gladiator 2.
following the death of the main
protagonist Maximus at the end of the
first movie it wasn't clear what a
sequel might look like for many Russell
Crowe's role is inseparably linked to
the success of the historical drama and
so a sequel with a different main
character does raise some questions
although there is no in-depth plot
description yet there are some Clues as
to how the story will carry on in
Gladiator 2. the movie is set about 20
years after the events of the first part
so it also covers the real gap between
the two movies the focus is on Lucius
veras who is already known from the
previous movie as a child he is the son
of Lucilla and bears the same name as
his father who was a Roman Emperor for
eight years even better known as his
grandfather Marcus Aurelius the latter
continued to have a great impact on
Roman society for many centuries after
his death lucius's Idol however is
neither his father nor his grandfather
but Maximus who made a lasting
impression on little Lucius by being
Fearless in the arena in Gladiator 2 the
now grown-up Lucius will follow the
example set by Maximus this might not be
easy though since he can was from a
prestigious family it will probably not
approve of him following the path of the
Fallen General in Gladiator instead of
becoming a Roman Emperor himself so fans
can expect an ambivalent protagonist
with what is sure to be an exciting
story even though it's not quite clear
yet whether Lucius will also become as
much as a fan favorite as the brave
Maximus
some actors have already been revealed
who will definitely be among the cast of
Gladiator 2. in the starring role we
will see 27 year old Paul muscal who is
Oscar nominated for best actor in a
leading role for his performance in the
2022 film after Sun Also cast as a
significant supporting character is
Barry kyogen who is also nominated for
an Oscar for his performance in the
Banshees of inisherin the 30 year old is
to take on the part of the Roman Emperor
Getta and it can be assumed that the two
characters will not be very friendly to
each other an official confirmation of
his role is still missing however the
rumor has been persistent for several
weeks by contrast Denzel Washington was
also to take on one of the most
important roles in Gladiator 2 is
definitely confirmed to be joining the
cast this means that after more than 16
years the actor will once again be
working with director Ridley Scott with
whom he already worked in the crime film
American Gangster the Top Class cast is
also joined by Pedro Pascal the star of
series such as the Mandalorian and the
last of us will play a leading role as
well exactly which role he will play is
certainly unknown however moreover it is
unlikely that we'll see the two Dead
main characters Maximus and Commodus
again in an interview with the Ryan
tuberty Show Russell Crowe talked about
being very happy for Paul Mezcal and
also a little envious he considers
Ridley Scott's decision to produce a
sequel to Gladiator with Lucius as the
focus to be an extremely smart idea and
wishes everyone involved the best of
luck
regarding the production of Gladiator 2
more and more information is coming to
light allegedly the first take is set
for May 2023 and there are already first
shots of the set being built in Morocco
apart from that the filmmakers are still
keeping a low profile at least we can
guess from the pictures that a true to
original Arena will be built again even
though only the wooden foundation can be
seen so far filming should then be
completed in the course of the year so
that nothing stands in the way of the
theatrical release on November 22nd 2024
except for post-production alongside
returning cult director Ridley Scott
David Scarpa will take an important
behind-the-scenes part in writing the
screenplay he has already been able to
gather plenty of experience through
films like all the money in the world
and Napoleon and also replaced the
originally planned the Batman Author
Peter Craig we are definitely looking
forward to more updates and hope to be
able to report more about the shooting
of Gladiator 2 soon
if you liked our new original episode
about Gladiator 2 please give the video
a thumbs up and share with your friends
do you think Lucius can win the hearts
of the fans just like Maximus once did
wouldn't you believe the film won't be
able to compete with the original at all
feel free to let us know your thoughts
in the comments
[Music]